in this video we're going to use a
simple model for the loanable funds
market to understand a phenomenon known
as
crowding out
and this is making reference to when a
government borrows money to some degree
it could crowd out private sector
borrowing and investment and it could
have negative consequences for the
economy you might have less investment
as a result and you could have less
economic growth so let's see how the
crowding out can happen using this
loanable funds market model
so just to be clear what's going on here
horizontal axis the quantity of loanable
funds the vertical axis you have your
price of borrowing which is going to be
our real interest rate
and our equilibrium real interest rate
and quantity is determined by the
intersection between the supply of
loanable funds curve and the demand of
loanable funds curve so what happens if
let's just say step one the government
decides to borrow to fund some of its
spending what is going to happen to
these curves is one of them going to
shift
well sure if at any given interest rate
all of a sudden you have a big borrower
in terms of the government that now
wants to enter the market for loanable
funds at a given interest rate that's
going to increase the demand for
loanable funds so this step one right
over here is going to shift the demand
for loanable funds curve to the right
i'll just call that step one right over
there and so our new demand for loanable
funds
might look something
like this
and so let's call that demand for
loanable funds
prime so this is going to shift
shift the demand for loanable funds
to
the right
now what is that going to cause
well that is going to cause our real
interest rate to go up
real
interest
interest rate
is going to go up you see it right over
here our new equilibrium you do have
more loanable funds that are being
supplied and demanded that are being
borrowed so this is called this q prime
but you see this happening at a higher
cost at a higher real interest rate so
we call that r prime
well what's going to be the impact in
the private sector of a higher real
interest rate
let's imagine for a second this first
blue curve was just the private sector
let's say that the government just
started to borrow in this video shifting
the curve well if this was if the blue
curve was just the private sector at
this new interest rate the private
sector is willing to borrow a lot less
so we could say
private sector
private
sector
borrows less
and so what could that result in well
then you could have and this is the
negative effects of crowding out you
could have
because they're borrowing less they're
fueling less investment then you're
going to have less capital less
productive capital that you can use to
produce things so we could say less
capital accumulation
accumulation
which is just another way of saying for
example people are
investing less because they're not
borrowing as much investing less in
factory or some other thing that might
make people or in technology things that
might make them more productive and so
if you're having less capital
accumulation that means that you're
going to have slower economic growth
one of the ways that a country really
pushes its production possibilities
curve out or really pushes its long run
aggregate supply curve to the right and
has true economic growth is through
investment but if you have if your
borrowing costs are higher you're going
to have less investment less capital
accumulation and slower economic growth